hello and welcome to the shaky science
show where in this video we're gonna
talk about senescence cells and in
particular senescence skin cells known
as melanocytes and how they can drive
skin aging and the relationship between
that and telomeres so the majority of
the research that I'll talk about in
this video comes from a recent article
that came out at the end of last year in
EMBO and it's the mess of human
melanocytes drive skin aging see a
paracrine telomere dysfunction so
there's probably a lot of tons in that
that need a bit of explanation first
before we go into describing the results
and so because I research it and it's
the main focus of this paper will start
with cellular senescence so cellular
senescence is one of the hallmarks of
aging which I've mentioned before enough
of you but effectively it can be
characterized by two key characteristics
one of which is the prevention of
proliferation so the cells stop dividing
and then secondly is the secretion of
factors refer to as a senescence
associated secretory phenotype and so
proteins that are secreted from these
senescence cells include signaling
molecules and inflammatory factors and
they can be of also thought of as a form
of extracellular communication to the
surrounding cells and so senescence
cells can be considered a good thing or
a bad thing depending on context so it's
Nestle cells are thought to be good for
aiding tissue regeneration wound healing
and it's also known to be important for
embryonic development however as I said
some of these factors are inflammatory
factors and chronic inflammation is also
associated with cancer and aging and it
can also cause tissue disruption so due
to both these positive and negative
aspects to senescence cells it makes
them very interesting to study and so
some of the questions that are trying to
be addressed are what actually causes a
cell to become senescent in the first
place and then consumer some cells be
selectively killed and is the removal
actually a good thing
so it turns out there are actually many
different ways that a cell can become
senescent but the one that we'll focus
on here is DNA damage and then in terms
of being able to remove senescence cells
and effectively kill them we'll talk
briefly about analytics at the end of
the video and how that was used to
prevent skin aging so since we're
talking about skin what does the
structure of skin actually look like
so as I've drawn out here probably a
little bit mess messily that's a wise is
the epidermis where you can see the dead
layer Roselle's at the top and then a
load of cells known as keratinocytes and
at the bottom you see these melanocytes
which you can see interacting with the
keratinocytes and so the keratinocytes
are the ones that proliferate and
regenerates the skin layer so what
happens to the skin during aging well
there is an age associated skin thinning
and there's also a loss of collagen and
a gain of elastic fibers and the kind of
the reason why this might happen is
thought to be due to a lot of the
replicative capacity of these
keratinocytes so that regeneration and
repair of the skin layer is becomes
defective so we've talked about the skin
now we've talked about cellular
senescence the last thing we need to
talk about briefly our telomeres so
telomeres and telomere shortening or
another hallmark of aging so what art
elem is what we know is that often
referred to as the she caps on the end
of the chromosomes and so basically the
function of telomeres is to be a
protective structure because at the end
of these chromosomes you've got an end
of DNA is so you've got effectively what
looks like a double strand break and so
that gets protected and bound by this
complex of proteins known as the
sheltering complex and so this helps as
I said to prevent recognition of the
ends of DNA as being a double strand
break which is a form of DNA damage
however as a cell divides and replicates
these telomeres shorten and so if they
shorten over time you lose that
protection and you can cause DNA damage
signaling which can then drive
senescence however there's also
it's induction fear DNA damage that is
independent of the shortening of the
telomeres and so that's in particular
relevant to melanocytes that actually
don't proliferate much where it whilst
the keratinocytes do so now we are in
obsession to discuss these results which
I split into three key take-home
messages so the first one is senescent
melanocytes accumulate during skin aging
so how do you actually identify a
senescent melanocytes while identifying
senescence cells is no trivial process
but one marker that can be used is the
expression of p16
which is operating involved in the cell
cycle arrest and so in the study they
took some skin punch biopsies from
humans who they classified as being both
young and old and they took these
biopsies from this unhidden region
underneath the upper inner arm and they
looked for the expression of p16 and
they found that actually k localized in
these concern posed to the melanocytes
and that the levels were higher in the
older samples and interestingly they
also saw in the older samples a decrease
in the expression of sat.1 which is also
a protein that is it's decliners
associated with aging the second key
result from this study is that senescent
melanocytes induce telomere damage and
senescence in surrounding cells in a
paracrine manner so in addition to
looking at p 16 in these tissue samples
in the samples they also looked at the
telomeres and it looks at both the
length the telomeres and whether or not
the chilliness were damaged and so
interestingly they didn't see any
significant differences in the length
but they did see an increase in what I
referred to as Tufts and so these are
telomere associated face-i and this is
when the telomeres collude lies with a
protein mark known as gamma h2ax which
is a sign of the DNA damage signaling
respond
and say this was higher in the sample
some of the older samples so the number
of TAFs
and these senescent melanocytes was
counted and then associated with the
level of dysfunction in the telomeres of
the surrounding keratinocytes and they
found that keratinocytes surrounding
melanocytes with three tufts had a great
number of dysfunctional telomeres than
those with new tasks so they could do
this analysis by looking at different
markers for the telomeres for this DNA
damage mark and for markers that's
identify a melanocytes and so the Tufts
a wallet like the Google Chrome symbol
anyway these results made it clear that
the keratinocytes were being impacted by
the senescence melanocytes but the
question was how what's actually going
on so today this thing looks at this ASP
this secretory phenotype of the
senescence cells and they identified
three proteins in particular that were
much higher in levels and this was CCL
5nc axial 10 which are both chemokines
and referred to as signaling molecules
so how could these chemicals called
telomere damage in the keratinocytes
well using a variety of different
experimental tests using different
inhibitors they came up with this model
which is that as we said these nests and
melanocytes that secrete these
chemokines as part of the SAS one of
which is IP 10 this excl 10 actually
binds the receptor known as chcl3 and
downstream of this they saw an increase
of reactive oxygen species and that is
known to potentially cause the presence
of telomere associated fesai
and so this is a form of paracrine
signaling and so the last part of this
paper establishes whether clearance of
senescent melanocytes could have an
impact and what they saw is that it's
really use of a surrealistic drug they
could actually rescue epidermal a trophy
which is the thinning of the skin layer
using a 3d human epidermal model so they
treated these models with
compounds abt 737 senescent cells are
particularly vulnerable to this
compounds and so three of those
treatments the senescence cells can
undergo apoptosis which is a form of
cell death and when they had effectively
killed some of the senescence cells they
also saw a decline in the piece it's the
in positive melanocytes showing that the
Senna lytic was working but the cool
thing was that they also prevented the
formation of taff's in the keratinocyte
and so since skin aging is thought to be
due to the loss of the replicative
capacity of these keratinocytes this
therefore shows a direct link between
senescence and induction loss of Cronos
in a site proliferation and skin aging
and so the studies shows some potential
optimism in the use of senna lytx to
prevent skin aging so as always I hope
you've learned something and thanks for
listening